[Music]
the items we see on store shelves don't
show up there by chance
retailers decide what will occupy that
precious space
now a growing movement is trying to
ensure that black owned businesses have
an opportunity
to sell their goods in proportion with
the black population
it's called the 15 percent pledge and i
spoke with founder aurora james about
why she believes disrupting business as
usual
was the only option i was so
fed up as you know a woman and a woman
of color of being disappointed by the
choices that
people or companies were making but i
also realized that i
failed in a lot of ways to really ask
for what i
needed it was out of frustration that
fashion designer aurora james decided
she needed to be a part of the solution
[Applause]
in the aftermath of the killing of
george floyd
she took to instagram demanding major
retailers commit
15 of their shelf space to black owned
brands
i was having conversations with my
friends about all these corporations and
you know the donations that they were
making and i was really like no guys
like we need real change you know black
businesses are dying out
according to a report conducted last
june the national bureau of economic
research found that 41 percent of black
owned businesses have closed due to the
pandemic
compare that to less than 17 percent of
white-owned businesses
james founded her own luxury accessory
brand
brother vellis in 2013 and knows
firsthand the barriers black
entrepreneurs face
i really did that without ever having
even a loan from my
bank or a company credit card it was
always one of those things where i was
like oh you know it's weird even first
round of ppp
like didn't get it you didn't get it no
the bank said no to you i was able to
like get
get you know loans from various people
but to be honest they weren't healthy
loans that were helpful for my
businesses
they weren't loans that like any of my
white male colleagues in the industry
would have ever ever ever
ever ever had to get along with
committing shelf space
companies are asked to conduct an
internal audit of their current spending
power and contracts
allocated to black businesses i'm
curious
what you tell companies are going to get
out of it on the back end
when we look at consumer trends right
now we're also seeing that
people want to shop places that they
believe in
and they're not willing to just spend
money anywhere anymore
because we have fought hard for every
single dollar that we make right now as
americans
i'm wearing makeup and i'm totally
comfortable sephora was the very first
company to commit
we were very excited i'll tell you
within within minutes of
seeing the pledge artemis patrick is
executive vice president
and global chief merchandising officer
for sephora
within minutes of talking to aurora it
became very clear
that we were aligned that this is really
about a long-term plan
that builds a platform for black-owned
and black-founded
beauty prestige brands to grow and
succeed how specifically are you and
aurora working together
to tackle this big overall it absolutely
should be
that the the people who are creating the
brands should also be a representation
of the people who are buying the brand
sephora evolved an already existing
program
dedicated to women founders and created
a new initiative
that focuses solely on building black
indigenous
and people of color founded beauty
brands
it was very emotional marie claudio
amusa
and alice lynn glover created skincare
line edom
and are among the first group of women
selected so alice walk me through it
what is the process
like it was like winning the lottery for
me we then interviewed with the sephora
team
and i really have to give them credit
because i think when we're explaining
our product a lot of people struggle to
understand
exactly what we're talking about but
they themselves had a diverse panel of
interviewers
and so they really seemed to understand
what we were building and why it was
important
they met at google bonding over their
shared immigrant background
and being one of the few women in the
tech company
the two always discuss beauty but the
idea to start a brand
came years before it was back in 2014
and this very famous black hollywood
actress
was the face of a well-known brand and
they had just launched a fun
foundation product and i was like oh my
god someone that looks like me
i need to buy this product and i get to
the counter and i ask for my [ __ ] and
i'm like i want whatever she has
and the salesperson looks at me and he
says
oh we don't have your shade here so
the shades available they make the shade
they just didn't bother to put your
color in the store
yeah it's exactly that and i was like
okay i really need to do something in
this industry because if that's what i'm
seeing
i'm sure there are other pockets out
there where we can bring
change and more diversity for james it's
about
the pledge making a difference when we
are on the other side
what will society look like when you've
met these goals
when we talk about supporting small
businesses and we talk about supporting
small black-owned businesses in this
country what that really means is
supporting underprivileged communities
that need it the most
and it's important for everyone to
understand that the 15
pledge isn't just about positively
impacting black people
it's about positively impacting the
country at whole
and that's really the bottom line a
rising tide lifts all boats inc magazine
says that
minority women now control nearly half
of
all women run businesses women are the
backbone
entrepreneurs of you know this country
so you got to make sure that you know
they get a fighting chance and
even the playing field